are you dating anyone right now so
um yes i am dating uh
this guy is an engagement coming soon
period
like he's over there smiling so maybe
i want to get some life updates from
each of you lexi you want to take that
first
life update i have my first apartment
every other year that i've been here at
navarro i've
lived in dorms which is it can be
stressful because like you have to share
like a tiny room with one other person
yeah and you know like i just love
having like my personal space sometimes
so like that's been really awesome um
new tattoos i was gonna say there's some
new ink that i need to tell us about
blue sleeve coming soon what inspired
sleeve and will you show us oh yes okay
this one is like a skull with flowers
which is like kind of like a
representation
of my personality like dark but like
beautiful
at the same time and this one's a hazmat
hand
which is like a symbol of like good
fortune and it has a butterfly in it
and you know the moon phases and i
always call myself a moon child
i love pausing my hands just because i
don't know my luck is like so like
wishy-washy like i feel like a lot of
the times my luck is either really
really bad
or really really good and it's kind of
hard to find it in between and then
the butterfly is like number one i just
love the way butterflies
look but i also like really um connect
with butterflies because i feel like my
life has been like a metamorphosis and
like
i've been through some really like rough
dark times and like i feel like this is
like the butterfly stage of my life
where i'm like finally like getting it
together and like
going down the path like i actually like
want to like be on
and so that's one of the reasons why i
really like uh
relate to like the butterfly and um
i have some merch coming out soon
i actually have a shirt right here it's
just one of the shirts
but i'm gonna have like six items total
in my first drop it's just like one of
my drawings and it's it's like this crop
top
and the background drawings
wow that's so um and it's also
there's joggers or sweatpant joggers
that go with it
when will those be available it should
be out really soon
was that your boyfriend walking by yes
he made me
some pasta because i literally was like
today at practice
because i don't eat before practice
because like if i eat before practice
i feel like nauseous and heavy and like
i'm not able to do everything that i
need to do like perfectly
so like today was like just a really
like stressful day and like i was
getting like super hangry and like i was
like having a mental breakdown i
literally like you're so sweet
how has quarantine been on the
relationship good
yeah awesomely i feel like most people
like get sick and tired of each other
for being around each other for so long
but like
we've been like flourishing and thriving
and
that's how i just know that like we're
like meant to be because like if it
wasn't like we would have been at each
other's throats by now
is an engagement coming soon period
like he's over there smiling so maybe
yes no for sure yes oh that's really
cute
i'm very happy for you thank you gabby
your turn
first of all how are things with the
family and everything your family's
doing well
yeah so my family's doing really really
well they actually just helped me move
into my apartment also so me and lexi
basically
live all the navarro people live in the
same apartment complex yeah just like
lexi i'm back at navarro
and this year because it's like my true
last year
i really decided i'm like you know what
there's a lot of opportunities out there
but i really
feel like this is something that i want
to do
and i feel like it's something i need to
do because i'm not going to be able to
get this year back
and it's going to be the last like the
true last time
with the people that i love the most and
there may be opportunities but i really
feel like this is what i genuinely
love and want to do the most so i picked
with what my heart was going for and
that was navarro
what your career look like after this
year like can you still continue to
cheer
this is technically my third year
because this year was supposed to be my
last year but because cove had happened
we got one more year of eligibility back
so
this would be my third year on the band
show
this year and after that i'm not really
sure
like what i'm going to do i could
technically go to a university and cheer
for university which if i did
go to a university i could do texas tech
it's only a couple there or sorry it's
like five hours from navarro but
they're like probably one of the best
that's just you know if i decide to
stick with cheering if not
there's a whole lot of opportunities um
that you guys will
you know hear about later but it's all
really exciting stuff and as of right
now what i can tell you
is i'm going to start podcasts so i'm
really really excited for that
yeah what will it be about my podcast
uh is actually going to be called the
aftermath
and it's just kind of a way to because i
feel like a lot of people constantly see
like the success of
you know athletes like professional
athletes they only see like
what you know what goes on when they're
successful so i just wanted to get a
bunch of like different people
like athletes celebrities uh actors
whoever and just talk about like more so
you know the stuff that a lot of people
don't see
like you know get them to open up more
and when will this launch you don't know
yet
it should actually be launching in the
next couple weeks oh wow that's so soon
yeah i'm really excited i'm actually
like
i asked lexi about her boyfriend so i
have to ask you are you
dating anyone right now so
um yes i am dating uh
this guy his name is jordan and it's
funny because i met him
at navarro last year and
we dated for about a year or so and
we ended up breaking up it was very like
back and forth you know
just yeah kind of like it was just
you know we were like this all the time
we love each other but then the next day
we're fighting so
but now we're doing really really well
and he's actually
playing football at acu which is a
christian university it's about three
hours from navarro so i see him every
once in a while but
yeah we're doing really really good and
i'm trying to take things nice and
slow how long have you guys been
together this time
so we just got back together
right around i would say a few months
ago maybe
right about mid july okay that's very
exciting
yeah so i'm he's listen he's
so like he's great super super sweet
gotta you know gotta get a little kinks
out but
he's a very very he's supportive and
that's really all i can ask for he makes
me super super happy
and yeah he's a he's a great
great he's like one of my best friends
too that's why it's kind of like
you know it's not only is he my
boyfriend he's also my best friend